[Music]
since they put a remastered version in
theaters to build hype for Avatar 2
Slippery When Wet settle in for a
remastered honest trailer of the one we
made back in 2012 because let's be
honest a lot has changed in the last 10
years meter side blooms is that what I
used to sound like Avatar 2022
remastered Edition
journey to Pandora a world made of glow
sticks full of aliens who look like ugly
Sonic the cat they are the navi a band
of indigenous tribes who still manage to
stay extremely online it's a Global
Network and the navi can access it they
can upload and download data when humans
learn there's a fortune buried under the
Keebler Elf tree they call home they'll
do whatever it takes to capture all that
sweet sweet unobtainium inside
unobtainium well you think an obtainium
is a dumb name when do you hear about
real minerals
you are Chris Evans as Captain America
but did you know he was this close to
being Captain Jake Sully it was
parametrically instead of an actor
capable of making more than one face
follow Sam Worthington as a marine with
an incurable condition
no there's nothing wrong with using a
wheelchair but even in the future they
can't pick stupid me I'm just another
dumb grunk going someplace he's gonna
regret just relax and let your mind go
blank shouldn't be hard for you a theory
calls me skull
means [ __ ] when Jay Gets behind the
wheel of his custom Lincoln Navigator
he'll retrace The Familiar plots of
Dances with walls Pocahontas and
FernGully but when he's in his own body
he'll retrace The Familiar plot of a
content creator suffering from burnout
is this right I just
say whatever to the video log do I have
to do this now like I really need to get
some wreck no no
excuse me this is my video log here
until this vlogger decides to fully back
the blue and lead the navi Warriors to
one of the most predictable L's in
colonial history
oh you gotta be kidding me
dude gets bailed out by birds at the end
just an extremely dumb hero even by
Chosen One standards here I am
doing science
saving this white savior from himself is
natiri a navi who's 10 more jellicle
than the others
foreign
covers Jake with its special seed seeds
of the Sacred tree she'll stop trying to
kill him and form an unlikely romance
around their shared love of stabbing
dogs
as Zoe Saldana Rockets to fame with the
first of her many billion dollar movie
appearances proving that old adage that
once you go Blue you'll never go black
don't forget other supporting characters
like Mr business I love this Potter
Ronnie Colonel Soldier
and Dr samples so we should take a
sample if they see us taking our samples
I would die to get samples
take some samples but you will forget
about them because this movie isn't
about the characters it's about The
Vibes where you can throw on some 3D
glasses and Google around in a Neon
Jungle or soar through the floating
mountains with your hot princess
girlfriend James Cameron knows you're
just here to get away from it all like
how he's just here to fund his crippling
addiction to submarines poor guy misses
out on so much Under the Sea Bill Paxton
was on the deck of the Titanic when 9 11
happened with Jim Cameron so Marvel at a
decade old film that looks better than
movies released six months ago that
still resonates because it Taps into
some of our deepest unconscious desires
like get out in your way into a
minority's body oh come on you ain't got
no excuse
finally getting a good night's sleep no
matter how much construction noise is
going on outside
and having ponytail sex with anything
that moves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take me back to Pandora James I'm ready
story
aquamarine Jake's sarcastic little laugh
liggy lass Ripley's Believe It or Not
you can't just change your eyeliner and
expect us to excuse your war crimes oh
you can good to know Antonio's turd
nuggets Duke Nukem 3D a crypto Miner and
how to [ __ ] your dragon that's right
you're mine
James and the Giant preach
wait a second what am I seeing Michelle
Rodriguez and Sigourney Weaver in the
movie before Oh no
slide slide slippity slide I'm hitting
switches on the Block in a 65.
moist Talbots
feed me Seymour the Panthers are going
to the Super Bowl